you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme concerns the uk's
climate credentials as the hosts of cop
26 could be undermined
as mps support a cut to the foreign aid
budget
could natural gas be used to create
clean energy
we find out how a net zero emission
power station
might work and the new edition will soon
be
beavering away to help flood management
on exmoor
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we start with a decision
by mps to support a reduction in
overseas aid spending
from 0.7 of gross national income to 0.5
the government says spending on climate
initiatives is protected
but with the uk hosting the crucial cop
26 summit in november
a whitehall source told sky news the
summit president alok sharma
is concerned a failure to honour the
commitment will make it harder to
persuade developing countries to sign up
to emissions targets
here's what conservative mp tim lauten
has to say in the commons
global britain is about projecting not
just military and diplomatic influence
not just about pursuing new trading
and investment partnerships beyond this
continent but complementary to this is
the exercise
of soft power climate change is a major
focus of it we're
chairing cop for goodness sake what
message does that send
to the rest of the world this is a force
economy at the wrong time
well our correspondent katerina vatosi
is in bangladesh where alex sharma
visited recently to discuss the issue of
climate finance
and katarina what role does uk aid play
in a country like bangladesh which is so
vulnerable to climate change well a lot
of the aid money which the uk government
has spent in bangladesh over the past
decade or so
has been involved in projects that have
touched people dealing with the very
immediate threat of climate change here
in bangladesh we spoke
with the director of one of not only
bangladesh's but the world's
leading and largest ngos it's called
brac and over the past decade there's
been 450 million pounds worth of uk
government money which has gone in
to financing many of their projects and
a lot of those
are to do with climate change helping
coastal communities
deal with some of the worst weather
situations
that have got worse progressively
because of climate vulnerabilities
over the past 10 years and the director
of that organization told us that the
the cut in the uk foreign aid budget was
like a gut
punch it would have a dramatic impact on
the people that had seen
the benefits of some of those programs
over the past 10 years but also really
alok sharma when he was here said that
climate financing was such a totemic
issue with regards to getting vulnerable
countries on board
heading into cop 26 so this will be seen
as another significant
damage to that reputation katarina thank
you
in today's other climate news the uk's
first marine park is one of five
projects getting a share of 50
million pounds from the national lottery
heritage fund
plymouth sound has received nearly 10
million pounds to help protect wildlife
and explore how
seagrass can be used to help the
environment grants have also been
awarded to a major experiment
in wet farming and a project to preserve
the cairngorms landscape
climate change could be treated as an
emergency in the same way as coronavirus
was according to researchers
glasgow caledonian university center for
climate justice is calling for
developed countries to give more money
and technology
to poorer nations to help them adapt
they also want governments to
share data with the public on the deaths
and damage caused by
extreme weather events the un has
published a new draft of a paris-style
agreement on biodiversity with
21 proposals to protect nature it sets
out targets to reduce
pesticide use eliminate plastic
pollution and put at least
a third of the planet under conservation
protection by 2030
the agreement will be negotiated and
signed at the next global
biodiversity conference in october
the environment agency says water
companies must do more to reduce
serious pollution incidents its latest
annual report found
none of the nine english water and
sewerage companies
achieved all of the environmental
expectations set out for them
for 2015-2020 southern water and
southwest water were the worst
performing companies
for cutting pollution last year and the
welsh government is encouraging people
to plant
more trees to help whales reach net zero
by 2050.
mps are working with farmers and
landowners to identify areas where new
woodlands could be created
it's estimated around 86 million trees
will need to be planted over the next
nine years
if wales wants to achieve its emissions
targets
to the united states now where after the
warmest june on record parts of the
country are experiencing
yet more extreme heat a weather
phenomenon
called a heat dome has developed over
the southwest with
temperatures climbing well above average
during the day and then not falling much
overnight
the intense heat has seen death valley
register what could be confirmed
as the highest ever recorded temperature
on earth
of 54.4 degrees celsius
well the severity of the hot weather has
reinforced the dangers of human-induced
climate change with scientists saying
that global warming
is making the situation worse well our
correspondent greg milam is in palm
springs in california for us now so greg
there are experts who've expressed
concern that the american west is stuck
in this cycle of heat
and drought and fire is there a plan to
try and break that cycle
well they're trying their best and it
certainly feels like that cycle now is
is somewhat inevitable uh the scientists
say these heat waves are getting more
frequent
they're getting more intense so what do
you do about that we know cities are
looking at ways you can adapt
designing a landscape to provide more
shade for example
even talking about whether people need
to work at night rather than during the
day
shifting that whole way we we live our
lives because it's more bearable at
night although
here actually at night the record
temperatures still the minimum
temperatures are
hitting records one meteorologist here
has said to us
in the last couple of days that he can
see a a situation in the next couple of
decades where a place like this would be
uninhabitable
simply because those temperatures are so
hot uh during the summer and of course
they're used to it here we're in the
desert
it's still extreme for them here but
there are tens of millions of americans
who are experiencing these heat waves
who don't
uh usually and that is what is unusual
uh this year
uh and on top of that of course we have
the fires the drought the wildfires that
are more intense
earlier in the year and spreading much
more quickly earlier in the year
again something that's very different
from from what's happened the heat
actually is easing over the next couple
of days but the question is after the
last few weeks
that a lot of people have here is simply
when is the next one coming
greg thank you the uk's first
net zero emissions power plant could be
built on t
side if plans put forward by a group of
energy companies
gets the go-ahead those involved claim
that it would mean natural gas could be
used to create
clean and efficient low-cost electricity
so how would it work well traditional
power plants generate electricity by
burning natural gas
as their fuel they use a turbine natural
gas is added
along with a stream of air which
combusts and expands through this
turbine
causing a generator to spin a magnet
making electricity
and because air is made up of nitrogen
oxygen carbon dioxide and several other
chemical elements the emissions left
over after the energy creation process
are a blend of all of those chemicals
now nearly all combustion byproducts
have negative effects on the environment
and on our health one way to try to
reduce the harmful emissions is to
capture and store them
but to do that you need complex and
expensive technology to separate out all
of those chemicals
the proposed development on t side aims
to simplify
that process chief executive of eight
rivers cam hosey
told us how fitbit cycle
it combusts the natural gas fuel with
pure oxygen
as opposed to ordinary air and
as a result the combustion product that
comes through through this system
is pure co2 and water which is used to
drive the turbine
and to generate the electricity because
the
system itself only produces co2 in water
the separation process to get to the
pure co2
is relatively easy and inherent in the
technology itself
as a result we end up with a pure co2
product which can then be
taken away and sequestered underground
but would this process really result in
fewer emissions and is that the same as
net zero
well joining me now is dr mai bowie a
specialist in carbon capture and senior
research associate at the center for
environmental policy at imperial college
london
uh welcome to you do you think this
could be a game changer a way of
reducing our emissions
uh yes indeed so carbon capture and
storage is
well recognized as a fairly essential
technology
in our transition towards net zero
when you're looking at different sectors
so for example in the power sector
you need these types of ccs technologies
to kind of provide dispatchable reliable
power to help balance the intimacy of
renewables
um in you know the industrial sector
there's not many other options so you
need
carbon capture and storage technologies
to help reduce emissions there so
overall you know in across different
sectors you've got the need for ccs
and also for co2 removal to kind of get
negative
emissions to kind of offset other
emissions where we can't abate
co2 and presumably the technologies are
different depending on which sector
you're talking about
how advanced are we in those
technologies
here in the uk yes so
normally there's a portfolio of
different technologies and they have
different levels of technology readiness
level or trl
and the good news is that we do have
technologies at that higher trl level
and
ready to kind of deploy today so if we
wanted to do
carbon capture and storage it is very
much uh possible to do
um just using these sort of higher more
advanced
developed technologies and and in the
future
how big a role do you think that power
plants with carbon capture
will play in the race to net zero or do
you think the main focus will remain
on renewables so i think it's a
combination of all the different
technologies
um and you know it's better to kind of
minimize the risk in our transition to
try to use a portfolio
of technologies and diversify and so the
issue with renewables is the
intermittency
because you know if the sun's not
shining or the wind's not blowing we
don't have energy and
you can still have batteries energy but
it's slightly
um you know maybe not quite there yet on
in terms of the large scale
capacities that we may need and also in
terms of the cost so having ccs as sort
of the backup
will definitely be needed dr maybe
thanks very much indeed
and finally the national trust says the
first baby beaver to be born on
exmor for 400 years has been captured on
camera
the baby known as a kit was filmed at
the charities holnercut estate in
somerset
where the animals were reintroduced last
year the beavers help with natural flood
management
and improve biodiversity on the estate
well that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show sky sports news hits
the road in an electric car
visiting sports venues across the south
of england on a mission to go green
thanks for watching see you then